ось символ банку у начальники на геоні
банку
від обіду два плюс два працював зателефонували
прийдіть в оливковому коли перевірку
скільки вам доведеться телефон та вигоду в
самому аеропорту у мене було два заходи
ниток від нового аеропорту це не
тільки термінала і вежа зараз нам ти
будь то довжина різьби повернувся але якщо
нападуть на закликайте підемо воювати так
російська армія розумних посмішка армія
багатий танки в
алло
це комуна страшна кіма любить
[музика]
всередині назвати і вимагати до Івана
противник телевежа редактор програм на
самому минулого прийшла вина треба було і
ти його you wait і дати його я був
налаштуваннями службі а-95 бригаді
2034 рига ну і я касин екшену знаємо
нібито ти так ви їх посмішка та глядачі
мені мама з детства говорила людина
мають лінкора джек пак і так хоча б за
1 од показуючи до світла fishing це
живу та проїхав будинком шкірки вайман демі
весь колонку цього покарай готовий
говорять а поки дружина молода сидіти
зводили прийдіть у
скільки доведеться телефон прийшов
щоб підірвати
ми назвати імена дідові група зони бізон
учасник російсько-українські видно один
забралися в 13 рапорту званих кібер ю ну
щоб чогось з обох часів кіборгом там
мідними дідусями ветеранами та героєм
напрямку монета до міхур зараз і
будуть Андрія можуть її робота шолома
обробляти його в банку в начальник
не бачила ним банку патин проти днів
торгової компанії житінський швидко
має кому на правій
ногою як би жити а українською
стандартним українцям та націоналістом
зазвичай по російському кого це
відсотками заповнення російських морщів
почалася війна, а я нормально люди на
взяв підгодівлю вловив пришила та спаму
для того, щоб не мобілізувала з криком
вона з пацани це тумани білі скелі по
токіо застануть здоров'я у них проходить
вниз руку службу і в завалений додати
медового то винуватці тодес творилося a
battalion карпатської січі їх обсі їх у
цю демін закопаного ламінін ну і я
погоди все-таки чоловік по трапу копати
кіска травою мафон
ще не розумію разу не брешу та й дому
голим і зараз бралася а крим для хотіли
було торгувати на світ правило в
генетику і згустилася і гадів і
якийсь момент у нас прилетів режик
ріжок porsche пас тренувалася
розумієш чопа тобі стріляє гострий
патрона квиток туди проклали white його біля
них 3 ухиляєш пачку син уже ми
вважаємося руку
ну пролетіла ok ось ти знаєш до ризикував
селитися в тебе він теж все довго ти за
мати і ти знаєш що тревор досвід і я
готова теж ось фіга сидиш ти говориш
руколу кінну щоки сибуя screen view
шви бойова
прокидається він тобі про куди ці такий
шлях і пофігізму пофігізму і коли
кожен день прикол я шкіряна 12
артилерія спочатку ти на марсі тут
хапайся читали працював джедаям кінця
гдр його будь то ямка бтр ну якось себе
я у люду і саму за хвіст там це вже
pitkin ці кохання штам що якщо ти
смішний фаталіті
ми можемо ми можемо провалив яхти
попроситься заїкання сигнальник
моя but i поручні травня дадуть убиті
пляшок
[музика]
у
метро за 1 11 чортова фура kombat навіть
хабсі ви можете поїхати в додатковий
термінал
93 вас трьох від з ран завтра дзвінку
висновок про я моїх написано котики типу так
звичайно в результаті
ну і так поїхали на склі раппорт
складає 1 а я би повернувся з точка
зору там війни цих з поплутав їх
мутація було жорстко там вже
на ти зараз плед або дозволив зама 14
руку і хто за терміналом же принципом він
заснував
металокаркас там замовляєш помістимо
ті ж мастям розвалювалася а бажаємо і в
бойлері на її обличчі картонними стіновими та
ногу і текли морозу і розплакалася це
з приводу -30 у нас так там і сидама
спала було на градусі вазі та ти ж
танцюють про це вага натіки весь масив і
до вихідних wh кого для моно рапорт з
ніж ассасин такі дух побратимства киян
бо чиніди на вині
[музика]
дратувалась і цьому у стрілку дня
починається національне що він луця
просто був жорсткий лап структуру
struther багато там все про
чому могла миша підходом до командира
оборона від фарбу 90 батальйони bull
так і душман у нього позивні звідки мені
про тип що роботою жінок запечатані жінки
захищають і мінські сади типу млинець
про це кіно стріляє і на такі ну
типу стріляють купувати запилювачам
зворушлива година музика мені нова дума
ще набираючи 102 козаки за раз ви
клаптиками
споживаємо інші думаєте споживаних
селидове музика покарає так і так
починається історія ж у нас хочуть
російсько буду російського як ось у нас
дуже вбт нас хочуть убити тому що
стріляє
протру відразу ви зробите по kei д.в.
музика ну зараз ми туди і донецький
аеропорт нова термінал хула на паузу та
управ tupperware інформації то
геніального википає маска так сиджу на
ці котів ну це в днр ну ми україна
ціна наша зона вид паве дальності
музикант кожен млинець митрофанова в днра
у нас там послав і позначилося дзвоніть
тому ферменту в Україні золото кадик
ніякого на пауза і туди пропущена
прибутки t6 тут ну так ну і щоб це я там
ж ви бачиш у цьому роботів завалюється
до аеропорту замовлення на ви маєте рацію так я
чесно що настане щось ротою commuter
case крок широко нам стріляти чого як же
стріляє в якусь міліцію ми вислухали
на свою адресу дуже багато специфічна
comply мантію та знайти мандрівники нову
трубку
наш подружилися за місяць свою броню не
знає скільки у рапорті аеропорт
заїздами хочемо пройшла зима і холодно але
ви ж вона вже вбила чорним від лиха у нас
і прострілена просто синтезовані
підірваний на вітер холодно ми скрізь
регулювання рівня та в лінці ридом
такого вже формати на неї чо'галл нічого
було все вже розбито була мало не на
мить стріли візьмемо булочки донскова взяв
і
привели до того, що вам складеться ще ось
це ось і легше скроню вивозили за
рапорту вивели sky
of попросив і частіше непотрібністю а я
обожнюю що таке моє but i музи ще
показує індекс позиції свої леті до
річки особливості промовам і передавав ніде
було зберігати не домоглася барикад і ви
вирішувалася дати палацу та інші світлові
when i світової війни щоб тут
показують труби експозицію війни
росії з україною у
до розколу 5 ескудо і я потрапив стежками
на дискотеку через три дні я по ній
азарус вміє дарувати але туди пішов мене
накрило траха сид 6 а укус музика
добр а так і вимив і тут починається
слабо воїнам ато у мене накрило я вважав
плаката на них лікті забрав і я говорю
не ті люди на розуміють прочитаємо вона
каже на не скажу вже підросли до
писанини з висоти в одному приміщенні бич
лише два-три дні можна закритому
адаптація прийшла новизни тес була акція
три спортсмени 2015 руку про ти прийнято
проти наганяв сява його статусу донбасу
принципі я екватором
нами хочу на цій наше вийшов сказати про
своєю не дозволено закрив і починається
що хан і на
я поміняюсь у центрі що хануман та
прилітаючи пласта кого пляж case сторони
адже ось і linkedin я беру коли я назад
він і починають наступати хапаю дав ще
є господь прапора
валялася на
асфальті хапаю q і просто танення б
просто
ти кабана просто щоб не підпускати це
саботаж у людей виманити і явно не
оскільки вас своя битва вдома на ну і
сам не
shell прийшов та
активному через масові заворушення
чистим тут нам на гору і суди бою у
здається оки а
world war ii з ними на виході метушня
допомогою сезонного чого
залежать не садовий якщо знаєте ж ви
вийшли про приходив
треба знає такі скільки ми на був у
кабіні подібної до замкненого ти зараз
ходиш по пиву ти приходиш у будинок у вас
то б все дістало все не став і краса
результаті книжок
країна така фігня і обидва накручувати з
розуму на бочку з неживим волога не стане
вінка ж давай синку ти сюди поверни з
тут нічого не зміниться там потім довжина
тут людожер жив і так і живуть 8 років у нас
висимо рокки винокурня не нашому стояти
російською весь копію мережу або sim рокки
він і моїм круто типів то малювання
техніка
яка дешеву техніку
зате звикла ви не готова сюди
села
88 руки в мій травень можуть біля води секунда
треба холодний музику макото
ніг і так що нападуть закликати і димова
його to you did будь-який помінявся всім
чотирнадцятому кричати іван III папе за
вийшла об'єднати вина люди які у 14
15 уроках і матч воїни так само
нині богинею давати нашому 20 росії все
звук ладу і на нас на мою скувати і
шкірного руку шкірна зима
1014 урок удачі на початому конфіскувати
всі ми читаємо моноподу
відразу дрібниця так серйозно
їх за раз вона була така російська армія
посмішка армія а багатий to thank сил у
а ви
на якому вона страшна кемаля віце тато
подругою вина з русів у нас уже і так і
ми воюємо і в 14 воювала і за раз кулю
йому тому
з російським та регулярними військами
тієї армії у нас за 1 сет не така до
чотирнадцятому тут-то екшену і бдк якщо
сторони не я дала крутий думка прикус
місті спальника розрахунки за 2 дні
російські танки будуть у Києві на будуть
kicad та нікуди не збираюся та парнасі я
скажу скажу скільки там за розпізнати
заявляв мільйонів це раніше
нагадує дуже рецепту а
адже всі люди так зі мною зими
мого цих у сиригу лярн їх рис ніж роль
чим батальйоном та почуття територіальної
оборони так само їду твого батька в цей
ескіз людовика прийшла фронті сама
бойових до світла
[музика]